[Music]  i think he's either ahead of schedule or  on track one or the other and from what  i've gathered he's making great strides  he's back in the gym moving around  hitting pads and stuff nick sick  continued by sharing the most difficult  thing about coaching the ganu through  the injury the biggest thing for me as a  coach what i miss out on is time of  growing areas that we can improve on  that's where i get like oh man we're not  doing enough x y z and i'm okay with  that we don't have a fight lined up or  anything right now his main focus is  getting his knee rehab to the point  where he can get back in the lab and  start doing these things again hopefully  and it sounds like for what he's saying  that if something were to happen it  would be the end of the year or early  2023  [Music]